[Inaudible].
If I asked you to name the biggest company in Latin America,
in terms of market value, many of you think of giants like Petrobras,
the Brazilian oil company, or America Movil,
the multinational telecommunications company founded by Carlos slip.
You may even think of banks like Brazil's,
it's how or mining corporations like the Brazilian Bali or the Chilean called
Belco
Unless you follow the latter market very closely, or you live there,
of course you will most likely be surprised to hear that it's an e-commerce
company that is making the run for first place. And if that didn't surprise you,
the more stunning news is that the company in question is also Argentinian,
especially when we see headlines like that.
Argentina's economic wounds send companies, fleeing investors, fear,
leftist governments, interventionists moves to stabilize, struggling economy.
The financial Titans.
I'm referring to is Mercado Libra, uh,
giants that is listed on the NASDAQ along with other stock exchanges.
And that at the time of preparing this video,
the market value is that just over 50 billion,
Something like the Latin American Amazon, although in reality,
Mercado Libra is much more like Alibaba because unlike the North American giant,
this South American Titan that already operates in 18 countries in the region,
rarely trades in itself.
Nice.
It works as a kind of marketplace that makes available to buyers and sellers,
all the services they need in exchange for a small commission for each
transaction and service provided buying and selling logistics,
financial operations, et cetera, et cetera.
The fact is that with more than 44 million buyers and 11 million sellers,
this is by far the largest e-commerce platform in all of Latin America.
It's been a huge commercial success,
which as you can imagine has also become a huge financial success.
Mercado Libra shares have been one of the best investments of the last.
Okay.
Illustrate that point. If in 2010,
you had invested $10,000 in shares in this company.
Those same shares would be worth almost $160,000 today.
That's if that you haven't sold them along the way, of course,
and appreciation that is six times higher than the one registered by the S and P
500 total return that is even including dividends.
This has made us here at visual politic in collaboration with value school,
ask a few questions. What is behind such an increase?
What business model does Macondo Libra have?
What are its main strengths and weaknesses? What does the market make of it?
Well, as always in this video, we're going to answer all these questions,
but first you have to get to know the business model of the biggest Argentinian
company of all time.
Much more than online shopping.
God. A Libra was not a company founded in a garage far from it.
It's co-founder and president Marcos Schell Perrin was studying for a MBA at
Stanford university in 1999. When he mapped out this potential business.
At.
That time micro-scale Perrin decided study and worked in the financial
department of the Argentinian oil company YPF but when Repsol took control of
that company, he found himself unemployed. It created a kind of now more,
never situation for him.
So Galperin calls on his contacts to move his project forward.
Even from very early on,
it obtained the support of significant investors and entities as prominent as JP
Morgan, Goldman Sachs and Banco Santander in October, 2001,
just two years after it's launched McCarter Libra signed a partnership agreement
with E-bay whereby the American company became its largest shareholder a status
they maintained until 2016.
But the fact is that since its expansion began, it has been unstoppable.
And what began as an e-commerce space,
that is a simple space for buying and selling has become a whole commercial
ecosystem present in 18 different kinds.
[Inaudible].
This company currently operates with the following six divisions,
first Mercado Libra, which is strictly speaking the e-commerce market.
Then.
There is Mercado Pago,
the FinTech service division that deals with digital payment methods.
It's roughly equivalent to what ant financial with its Alli pay system is to
Alibaba and take note,
because as we will see later on this division already accounts for most of the
company's revenue,
and it has even begun to deliver products such as investment funds to its
clients.
In third place.
We find Mikado envious, which is in charge of logistics. Yeah.
Mikado shops, which is the Latin American Shopify.
That is to say it offers software and templates to be able to create and manage
online stores.
In.
Fifth place, Mercado Libra, publicity,
that which manages the online advertising within the planet.
Form itself, and finally.
McCarter credit over a purely financial arm dedicated to providing cash advances
and small loans. Yeah.
Sellers and buyers.
As you can see, just with Alibaba,
this company has gradually extended its activity to new markets. Well,
the fact is that with all these lines of business Mercado Libra achieved a
turnover of almost $2.3 billion in 2019.
I figured that in 2020 could exceed 3.5 billion.
Now wait a minute.
How can a company that had the turnover of just over 2 billion in 2019 and lost
almost $200 billion be valued at over 50 billion?
What does the market see in this company? Well, let's take a look.
The dream of Eldorado,
let's do that.
Between Tierra Del Fuego at the Southern most tip of South America and the
border with the lifts, some 655 million people,
almost twice the population of the United States with an average per capita
income, similar to that.
China.
However, despite this in the Latin American and Caribbean region,
e-commerce spending represented only 4.4% of all retail sales in
2019, by comparison,
this figure was almost 11% in the United States and more than 20% in China for
the same.
Period, we would have to.
At least a decade in North American data to find similar figures to those that
Latin America has today in terms of e-commerce. However,
what this low figure presents is an opportunity for the future,
an opportunity that could drive the growth of the Macado Libra business for many
years to come.
And do you know what that has been precisely what's been happening recently
during the last few years,
the growth of e-commerce in Latin America has been very similar to that
registered in the rest of the.
Well.
The fact is that today the company featured in this video is by far the leader
in all major markets in the region, Brazil, Mexico, Argentina, Chile,
and Colombia.
So it seems to be in an unbeatable position to take advantage of the upsurge in
e-commerce that this region is experiencing. And just remember,
we are talking about a market of just over $80 billion in 2020,
that is expected to grow by 50% in the next three years.
He is alone.
This point,
we need to discuss an important issue that those of you who follow visual
politics know all too well,
Latin America is a difficult region to do business in only two of its largest
economies, Brazil, and Argentina even rank in the world,
banks doing business index or ranking that attempts to rank countries,
according to how easy it is to do business there,
their rankings are 124 and 126 respectively proof that in this
index, Latin America usually rates badly year after year.
And not only that trade in the region has some very unusual characteristics.
Barriers to international trade are high. Bureaucracy is suffocating.
The vast majority of companies are small.
And the proportion of transactions in the economy that occur outside of banks is
overwhelming. Well,
it is precisely in this environment that Mercado Libra has specialized at that.
That is something that could give it a certain competitive advantage.
Their knowledge of the local market may be more difficult to replicate then
simply copying models from other regions.
Well, in other words.
If there's one thing that makes this company stand apart,
it is precisely its ability to read and adapt to the regional reality, but okay.
Okay. This is easy to say, and it could just sound like a bunch of hot air.
So do you want a concrete example? Well.
Check this out. Latin America.
Okay. Is a region with many, many peculiarities, for example,
although it may be hard to believe according to existing research today in 2020,
more than 50% of the population does not even have a bank account.
And depending on the country,
the use of credit card or debit cards is only common amongst 20% to 55 of the
population.
And of course it goes without saying that this can be a huge problem when you're
trading online. If consumers don't have a bank account or use cards,
how on earth are they gonna.
Hey, you.
That is precisely why in 2004, five years after the company was founded,
Mercado Libra created Mercado, PayGo, its own payment platform.
Something like what Ali is in China,
a platform adapted to the local reality that even facilitates cash payments
using local locations,
such as convenience stores and take note because this division of their business
was not only a winner for the commercial division,
but since the second quarter of 2020,
it has contributed most of the revenue of the entire company.
Mercado PayGo is no longer only in charge of managing payments on the Mercado
Libra platform itself,
but has made the leap to the outside world where its growth is by the way,
even more phenomenal.
Their off-platform business has grown at an annual rate of 75%.
Over the past five years.
Take a look.
During 2019,
this division facilitated more than $28 billion in payments.
I figured that in 2020 could increase to around $40 billion.
And although Latin America continues to be the region of the world where cash is
King, the trend that is happening in the rest of the world is clear.
Cash is losing favor to the rest of the options,
which are becoming more and more extensive.
They have an incredible opportunity to become the company of prepayments and
Latin America. So dark Sean Murphy,
senior analyst and fund manager at GQ G partners.
This is what explains why in March,
2019 PayPal announced an Alliance with an investment of $750 million in the
Argentinian company and pay attention because in 2020,
this company has found even more unexpected wind in its sails.
Coronavirus.
Yes, yes, that's right.
McCarter Libra has been one of those companies that has benefited the most from
the pandemic. Why?
Because social distancing measures and fear of contagion have propelled its two
main business divisions like a rocket on the physical level, quarantine,
confinements,
and other social distancing measures have driven the transition to E commerce.
And on the other hand,
fears of contagion have accelerated through decline of handling cash.
Thanks to COVID consumers don't want to touch anything.
And that is creating a virtuous circle for us. Michael Maybeck,
president and CEO of MasterCard.
The pandemic generated significant changes in consumer behavior resulting in a
new milestone and the penetration of e-commerce and online payments in the
region. Pedro Arndt, chief financial officer, Mercado, Libra.
And all this is something that naturally has been reflected in the Mercado.
Libra is accounts. The second quarter of 2020 was simply a month of new records.
[Inaudible].
I'll give you an idea during this period,
the sales facilitated by Macado Libra grew 102%.
And the total value of the payments managed was hundred and 42% higher.
This is what explains why the stock price has had such positive growth
throughout 2020. Now hold on a moment because not everything is so rosy. Yes,
the company is growing at a dizzying speed of that. There can be no doubt.
For example, look out to this graph that shows how income has evolved since 26.
How about the, this graph must be viewed in tandem with this one.
As revenues have increased, the operating margin has continued to worsen. Why?
Well, it's quite simple, firstly, because in many cases,
mainly because it's the cost of shipments, the company sells at a loss.
And secondly,
because the company is spending a lot of money on marketing and on expanding its
capacity.
[Inaudible].
In other words,
Mercado Libra is following the trends of the new Silicon Valley and wall street
where growth comes first and profits don't matter so much. On the other hand,
it should be noted that the company shares are not exactly cheap. For example,
at the time of making this video, McArdle Libra was trading at almost 15 times,
the value of all its revenue forecast for 2020 while companies like Amazon or
Alibaba are trading at four and seven times, those values respectively. And if,
instead of looking at the revenue, we look at the bitter, which as you know,
is the gross operating profit before interest taxes,
depreciation and amortization.
Then this company is trading at a whopping 252 times.
It's a bit D 252 times.
It seems to believe that this company is going to grow like crazy over the next
few years until it becomes the new Alibaba or the new Amazon. The question is,
will it make it,
will it be able to meet its goals in a region as complicated as Latin America?
Does it make sense?
There's a company that loses money and has a turnover of just over $3 billion is
valued at over $50 billion. We don't know. Only time will tell. However,
if one thing has become clear over the last few years,
it is that this type of company is an incredible business, but at this point,
it's your turn. What do you think of Mercado Libra?
Do you think it could be a good investment opportunity?
Will it have to face new competitors as just in LeBron's Invesco's emerging
markets, investment manager suggests.
Mercado. Libra has no chance of winning the business of Mexico.
Amazon is free to operate there because of the free trade agreement.
And Walmart has a large presence through wall mix, Justin Levine.
Leave.
And the comments. So I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please hit like if you did, and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
And also the channel is possible because of Patrion and there were patrons on
the platform,
please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always.
See you in the next video.